البدايه من ايران حيث اعلنت وكاله اسنه
تنفيذ حكم الاعدام في اربعه ايرانيين بزعم
ارتباطهم بالمساد الاسرائيلي الوكاله ذكرت
ان الايرانيين الاربعه الذين تم اعدامهم
ادونه بالمشاركه في تدمير ممتلكات خاصه
وعامه وذلك بالتزامن مع الاحتجاجات وبعد
محاكمه سريعه كما حكم على ثلاثه متهمين
اخرين بالسجن من خمسه الى همم 10 سنوات
اعلنت منظمه العفو الدوليه ان 28 ايرانيا
من بينهم ثلاثه اطفال معرضون لخطر الاعدام
مؤكده ان السلطات الايرانيه تستخدم عقوبه
الاعدام للقمع السياسي وايضا لارهاب
المحتجين هذا وقد ذكر التلفزيون ايران
انترناشونال لان وثائق حصلت عليها مجموعه
قراصنه من وكاله انباء فارس طبعا هي تابعه
للحرس الثوري الايراني كشفت عن اعتقاله
115 عنصرا من القوات الايرانيه قوات الامن
الايرانيه لدعمهم الاحتجاجات التي ايها
البلاد التلفزيون اضاف ان العسكريين
يمثلون واحد بالمئه من عدد المحتجزين في
الاحتجاجات التي تجهدها ايران طبعا
احتجاجات تستمر للشهر الثالث على التوالي
وقد فشل النظام حتى الان في اخماده لكنه
وفي محاوله لتهدئتها اعلن المدعي العام
الايراني الغاء ما يعرف بشرطه الاداب
دعونا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا طبعا هذا القرار بالغاء شرطه
الاداب لم يؤثر على التظاهرات حيث اضراب
المحتجون وذلك الليله الماضيه ادرى النار
في مقر البسيج وذلك بعدد من المحافظات
وايضا المدن الايرانيه اذا عدد من المدن
الايرانيه ولكن في مدينه قشان وذلك
بمحافظه
امام الجمعه في ما اضرم اخرون النار في
اعلانات حكوميه في يزد وايضا في داخل
العاصمه طهران اي في ايران